hello everyone and welcome back to
rotten tomatoes is wrong it's your girl
jacqueline and back with mr mark ellis
pleased to see you sir especially given
everything that is going through the
news and in our heirs right now
seriously there is a whole lot going on
jacqueline but it is always great to be
on this show this show's my norm this is
this is what centers me you know if our
lives are a game of tag i look at rotten
tomatoes as wrong as bass this is where
yeah
nobody can tag us if you're playing
freeze tag i don't know if you ever got
into tv tag when you were a kid did you
ever play that one i have not played tv
tag tv tag is like if i tag you you're
it unless you say the name of a tv show
i guess that was hard to do when we were
kids and so if i wanted to tag you and
you said brady bunch then i'm like ah
okay i'm still it i gotta go find
somebody who's
doesn't own a television oh i think that
one would be a hard one for me if you
asked me to like name a vegetable like
i'd be out after four just kidding
you're right after carrots okay about
after carrots uh oh or maybe name a
holiday tag oh that's why they passed
the big bugs because quote a line from
the movie the holiday
or just go down the holidays i mean by
the time you get to arbor day this is
gonna be hard like you can get through
christmas and valentine's day but like
yeah quote a holiday i love that so if
somebody tags me i just think of any
movie gary marshall directed in his last
10 years of working and then it gets
really tough but we're kind of covering
not really all holidays but like as this
is the holiday yes
it's the
not a holiday it's the holiday yeah and
it requires the bee because this movie
is epic yes we're talking about nancy
meyer's film from 2006 the holiday it
currently has a 49 rotten score but an
80
fresh uh audience score and we have a
very special guest with us this week i
cannot believe this um any doctor who
fans are probably literally like like
with their earphones close to it because
you probably read the tagline that's
right we're talking to billy piper star
of such incredible things from like i
hate susie secret diary call girl of
course as i mentioned she was a
companion on doctor who and she's here
to chat with us about her directorial
debut rare beast but she's also here to
defend her love for our selected film
the holiday so before we bring her on
mark please sir if you will give us your
synopsis of the holiday see this is why
i love this show it's because we bring
on people who sing and direct and write
and act and all i have to do is give a
synopsis of a movie i just watched again
last night and that would be the
holidays so you have our two leads kate
winslet and cameron diaz kate winslet
plays iris and iris is just not doing
too well in relationship she has this
sort of on again off again with rufus
sewell but she wants to cut him off once
and for all and she feels like she needs
to get out of town to do that meanwhile
in los angeles you have amanda played by
cameron diaz who's like look my job i am
this big time hollywood trailer producer
and i just got too many things going on
and my personal life is a mess thanks to
edward burns i need to get out of town
too what do you know they find each
other's places on a home swap website
because this movie came out in 2006 a
home swap website they swap homes they
go on holiday to each other's places and
they live it up for a week unbeknownst
to them there's a gentleman in each town
who's looking for sort of the same thing
those gentlemen are played by jude law
who's gonna romance cameron diaz and
jack black yes kids jack black is going
to romance kate winslet they meet do
they live happily ever after well
at least until new year's eve i guess it
is one of the more modern classic
romantic comedies especially around
christmas time when this movie takes
place
love love love it i think they they end
up falling in love and heading off into
the sunset since cameron diaz does a
movie studio company
kovit has taught us she can do that
anywhere she'll be fine she'll be fine
cutting trailers from london let's keep
it real
sorry and my i think shortly after
february they probably had some like
weird fleetwood mac sort of romp with
all four of them and they just figured
it out and he's a book editor you can
edit books away from offices that's the
one thing now it's like now there was
like this romantic comedy back in the
day go the distance about a
long-distance relationship that doesn't
work yeah going the distance yeah that
one is not a thing anymore because we've
learned we can be at home but we're
going to take it back to the time when
this would have been a separation and
would have caused a breakup back 2006
with a little segment where our review
curation manager tim ryan tells us what
the critics and audiences were saying
about the holiday back in 2006.
let's do the little segment we like to
call two minutes with tim
[Music]
the holiday has a particularly strong
pedigree it's got four big stars at the
top of the marquee and cameron diaz kate
winslet jude law and jack black and it's
directed by nancy meyers the writer
producer of private benjamin baby boom
and the two father bride movies as well
as the director and producer and or
writer of the parent trap what women
want and something's got to give so this
kind of thing is totally in her
wheelhouse but whether the holiday is a
slice of warm feel-good comfort cinema
or a big slice of cheese is a matter of
taste
it's at 49 on the tomato meter with 158
reviews but it does have an 80 audience
score so what did the critics have to
say in a rotten review mary f polls of
the contra costa times wrote the problem
with nancy meyer's romantic comedy the
holiday is that it is contrived too long
and insufferably cute
however in a fresh review carrie ricky
of the philadelphia inquirer wrote is a
fizzy champagne cocktail that provides a
pleasant buzz many smiles and jude law
with the role of his career the rotten
tomatoes critics consensus reads while
it's certainly sweet and even somewhat
touching the holiday is so thoroughly
predictable that audiences may end up
opting for an early checkout time anyway
that's the holiday and jacqueline and
mark if you were a melody
you'd be only the good notes
back to you folks ah
thank you for that tim i know also
i'm not surprised it's 49 of the tomato
remember this mark the critics consensus
is supposed to reflect
the critical consensus i like that fizzy
champagne line though because that's
exactly what this movie is it's just a
nice pleasant first sip of champagne
sort of buzz that you can hopefully
coast on we'll see how we actually feel
about the movie just a little bit but i
think that's a that's why tim ryan is
the best in the business well done tim
also an app description for our guests i
think that she is also like a little
fuzzy ship sippers champagne herself and
i am ready for us to give ourselves a
glass that's right folks it's time to
bring miss billy piper on to the program
to rotten tomatoes is wrong where she's
going to talk with us about the holiday
this was recorded separately so have a
listen to our chat with billy
[Music]
helly welcome to rotten tomatoes is
wrong thank you so much for coming on
the show thanks for having me it's an
absolute um pleasuring and and i'm
flattered that you're having me on the
show
girl
i can't believe you're saying that
seriously for all the other doctor who
fans fainting that she is like you know
anyway jazzed at us let me tell you it's
the other way around but we're here to
talk about your new film your
directorial debut
rare beast but before we get there you
want to go ahead and i think correct the
record on something that i feel
similarly about and that's the holiday
which is currently rated 49 rotten on
the tomato meter but it has an 80
audience score and i'm one of those
votes so
uh i'm guessing you're thinking uh
rotten tomatoes is wrong because it's
below 60 and it's not considered fresh
but
why is rotten tomatoes wrong about the
holiday give us your your log line on
that well it's so funny because when i
read the list of films i was like oh my
god they they can't about the holiday
they just can't
and then when i started breaking it down
in my head um ahead of this interview i
was thinking
what
like
the holiday
is really really great and satisfying
at christmas
but when you try and when you try and
sort of fight for it
for the rest of the year i found it
actually quite challenging so um
so actually um
i don't know how much i can pull you
guys apart right now um on reflection
um but there are some things that i feel
very fondly towards and um and
yeah i mean let's talk about it no we
will um and also we've got a little bit
of la london swapping going on here
you're not coming to my house but i feel
it uh yeah
mark did you i know you revisited this
for the show i don't even think i know
your holiday thoughts and i know a lot
of your movie thoughts well you're about
to jacqueline and billy because it seems
like billy is clearly on the side of
fresh jaclyn's on the side of fresh and
i just got to say the holiday is one of
the worst movies to not watch at
christmas i love this movie i absolutely
love this movie rotten tomatoes is so
wrong about this i don't know why we
can't have nice things and look is my
l.a apartment the best home swap
opportunity somebody in london could
have no no it is not but if anybody
wants to come swap with me and take care
of molly the wonder dog for a week i'm
here for it you can feed her and i'll go
to london and i'll have a great time
with jude law or cameron diaz or
whoever's there i love this movie
because it's like we get two full
rom-coms in one movie yeah
also like real talk like i live in la
not in a house that is anything like the
gorgeous things that you see in nancy
meyer's movies but like sorry like maybe
i'm just the country girl i was like no
i'm about that like your your claw foot
bathtub
and that kitchen like please please i i
was so excited out but let's break it
down we're going to talk it all through
we're going to make our case for why
rotten tomatoes is wrong let's head on
over to our movie talk section
[Music]
okay so the holiday i have to say i
obviously think rotten tomatoes is wrong
i think it's brilliant i love jude law
cameron diaz and jack black in a
romantic film too like that was just so
brilliant and of course kate winslet is
everything but
when did you see it first billy like
when was the first time you viewed it
was it in the theater was it at home no
it was at home and it was probably about
a year after it come out
um so i missed
i missed the hype i guess
um so i was coming at it
probably with a flu because i always get
sick around christmas um
and i would have been watching it at
home so
i was snooky and
wanting to feel um
like a
warm and
slightly hysterical and and i get that
from that movie
it sort of plays i am not sentimental
at all and you'll see that from my film
like it it's so polarizing the the idea
that i would like
this film at all and make a film like
rare beast
and i'm only ever sentimental with my
children and sometimes my partner
um so but with the with
when it comes to these sorts of films i
genuinely just they buckle me
um especially if there's anything
british in them it just
plays into uh
so
much sort of sort of fond
um memories of um you know living and
growing up in the uk and of course when
you watch it in the movie it's also
horrifically far-fetched
but there are some things that feel kind
of um
beautifully familiar
um
i'm always happier in the movie when i'm
in the uk
oh
i could see that though because i'm
sorry i don't i mean arthur's great like
the the
the guy that makes her time in la great
but they've left out all the other
things that make it not great
yeah well she never has to like travel
too too far she goes to like one dinner
she goes to one event but she lives in a
home that allows her to just be isolated
which is why a lot like billy i i enjoy
this movie so much because i can
identify so much with kate winslet's
experience and cameron diaz's experience
sort of in different ways because kate
comes to this beautiful l.a mansion and
that's how i feel when i go on the road
to do stand-up and i get put up at like
a really nice hotel if i'm not like a
four seasons or a hyatt i am going to
play with the blackout curtains i'm
gonna play with all the cool technology
i never have to leave the room and i
feel amazing by contrast cameron diaz
getting to this nice little quaint
country house and deciding like look my
heart's broken i have no friends here
there's nobody to talk to so i'm just
going to make my own fun she opens up a
bottle of wine she puts on loud music
she starts dancing around i have done
those things as well yeah and so like
the dudes are great jude law is great
jack black's great eli wallach is
awesome as arthur but
i love
watching these two women continue their
romantic journeys and that's from a guy
who is pretty much at the end of his
romantic journey i don't have a soul
anymore and so i'm pretty much not
joking billy he's really not like i
would say
can we do this
any more
but the holiday makes me believe in the
holiday the power of the holiday makes
me believe in finding true love there
might have to be a home swap involved
but that's the that's what a great
romantic comedy to me does is it makes
me have that fantasy in the same way if
i'm watching star wars i believe that
this could happen in outer space
somewhere when i see romantic comedy i
believe that this this could actually
work out for old mark ellis for a couple
years no
i know it's a real reflection it's a
real sign of the times i meant i think
people were genuinely a bit more
optimistic when this movie was made for
that truth
was that when it was made in 2000 yeah
2006 and that was what i was going to
say so i didn't see this in the theater
because as folks listening to the
podcast know that sort of like
late 2000s to you know early 210s that
that was the uh lots of alcohol and bars
days i was more like jude law in that
respect but like every night of the week
and so like my movie watching was was
small but there's a station here in the
states that they play this as like part
of the christmas re-watch it's tnt they
always have the holiday and christmas
story and i caught it on one of those
and now it is one of these like i have
to watch it every christmas like it's my
die hard in a lot of respects because
i'm like you i'm pretty cynical about
romance outside of movie theaters but
like inside movie theaters i'm like of
course bridgette is gonna be with darcy
of course he's you know she's gonna say
i'm the girl looking for a boy at the
end of notting hill and this movie has
one of those scenes too at the very end
which is one of my favorites but
billy what about you what is your
favorite like scene from the movie
because i have a few but it's mostly
towards the end so i want to see if you
have some maybe early ones oh mine are
early actually mine are in the office in
the beginning um
[Music]
because
even though i've never worked in an
office
um
and you know i do feel like these things
are slightly pushed
i just know
that
kind of woman
and that kind of man and that kind of
environment on on some level that feels
so
um
bleakly british um
that um i sort of relish that i mean
it's really not the first scene in the
film but it's something that i feel
particularly
tied to just because it's all so
um
hopeless and um
and twee
so that for to set it up for folks this
is early when
is character
yeah yeah kate wins character finds out
that jasper the man who refuses to let
her
fall out of love with him which is like
a real thing where the dudes just like
keep her parked with like little bits of
affection um he tells her he finds out
that that he is engaged i have a tip for
you
excellent a wedding was privately
announced earlier today that i don't
believe any other paper in town notes
about and i want you to be the first to
report on this particular union as it is
between two of our most esteemed
colleagues may i introduce the newly
engaged sarah smith allcott and
jasperbloom
and she's never known and she's just
like literally heartbroken about the
idea of it and i i do love that one as
well it is it is one of my top ones
because in addition to the bars part i
was also iris and for the early part of
the 2010s and late 2000s so
and i have a feeling that you're very
interesting maybe a little jasper
probably not he's a jesuit boy i don't
think you're a jasper but i got a little
look
all cards on the table every guy's got a
little bit of jasper in them yeah every
guy has a little bit of edward burns's
character but that's why those scenes
are so crucial to these movies because
we are instantly rooting for kate and
for i'm rooting for kate more than
cameron because like cameron's got this
great gig and she's just really working
herself too hard more than anything else
but i do love the scene where
we kind of fourth wall it and it's like
the movie trailer voice
cameron's like i just thought that was
like a cool trick
that you wouldn't normally see in a
rom-com but jacqueline as you know i am
my favorite star wars movie is return of
the jedi one of the big reasons is
because we all win at the end and
i love the winning at the end of this
movie where it's new years we just had
christmas and it's new year's and
everybody's actually meeting for the
first time because you had this nice
home swap and you had great results in
your personal life but can we actually
all be friends in real life that scene
lends me to believe yes so the ladies
can pair off and dish and jude and jack
can find something to talk about the
kids are having a good time i love that
the good time continues through the new
year because that just shows the promise
that this isn't just some one-off thing
we're going to have many more holidays
with this cast i want a sequel give it
to me i am with you on that one
yeah
i mean just the concept is so
unbelievably dated and there's some
women just hanging around for men in the
in this
really desperate way
now just suddenly feels so tone deaf
um
but um
so i'd i would be interested to see what
steer it uh it would take in a sequel
oh yeah i wonder if they'd be like
really we moved our entire world for
those two and i would love for them to
also make reappearances too because they
they got to set the the other side of
the story correct if i was going to talk
about a scene though that sort of like
hits down for me i'm a tcm classic movie
girl and basically every time arthur
comes on the
movie i like my heart melts like i think
of my grandpa who was literally sitting
me down to watch tcm he was not working
for louis mayer but i just i felt like
he was the embodiment
i felt like he was the embodiment of
billy wilder inside this movie which if
you don't know he he wrote one of the
all-time great romantic comedies the
apartment and i just felt so much of
that energy in this and so uh yeah every
time arthur comes on but the very first
scene where she rescues him
and and you see uh his oscar and then
also when he talks about
you're a leading lady playing like
you're the best friend
like that is a great line like you're
not the best friend uh those moments
between iris and arthur i loved you law
i love cameron diaz there's so many
other great moments cameron diaz like
tipping up the wine at the store
kill me live live i know that moment
girl i feel it um
also going on vacation and eating what
you want like that is like another
emotion that i was like so feeling uh
yeah
what about you billy is there another
scene that's sort of like when you think
about this movie fondly you're just like
yeah this is the one i'm gonna pull up
on youtube maybe
oh god um
i guess the jude law arriving
um just because it's so
brilliantly cringe it's like it's
i don't know there's just something so
unbearably charming about it
perfect such a perfect scene yeah oh
it's the perfect scene and you're taken
to this world where
you
imagine yourself at christmas and you're
in this sort of cozy environment and
jude law
turns up you know what i mean you're
going to get me
at the local pub
and you don't have any sort of
obligations family ops obligations and
it's all to play for it's a nice scene
because it allows for fantasy that's
what i like about it it allows you to
imagine
your life at christmas like it used to
be like
20 years ago
honestly and like it you know in a lot
of ways i mean like this is like early
days of like social media like those two
would have just damned for like
16 you know
that's why we like it so yes yeah it's
like it's actual people yeah in real
life and in different ways and so like i
like in this movie i think a normal
romantic comedy is like a snickers bar
where it's it's just everything's packed
into one this movie is like a twix where
we get two different sides and we have
one relationship angle and then we have
a totally different one because the way
that jack black and kate winslet get
together it's that's much more mark
ellis where it's like yeah you just
become friends and then you realize oh
wait i really am actually in love with
this person with the jude law arriving
with billy's scene it takes place
early-ish in the movie because cameron's
character has just gotten to england
she's settling in the home she's trying
to figure out it out she's trying to
figure out how she can have a good week
here away from work dealing with her
heartbreak jude law shows up and the
genius of that scene is that we have
been set up to as soon as we meet rufus
way i i don't like this guy and i like
this guy and edward burns like this
guy's got ulterior motives so we assumed
the same thing with jude law and it's a
smart move by nancy meyers to be like no
i'm going to turn that on its ear a
little bit later in the movie when it's
revealed no this guy's actually a
widower he's been dealing with his own
version of heartbreak and he's got two
little kids and so it's just it it's we
meet a character and then we learn more
about them in the next scene and it
totally changes that scene when i
rewatch it because this is one of the
movies i'll rewatch every christmas and
so it just lends a different sort of
subtext to when jude law first shows up
knowing what's going on
oh and can we add a rufus uh is the
great actor uh rufus seawell who plays
uh the jasper but let's talk about a
typecast like any time he shows up in a
movie now i'm literally like what's he
about to do so anytime he's like a good
guy i'm like kind of happy about it i'm
like he just has all those faces like
you might be doing some nefarious things
um it's so interesting that we talk
about jack black because you know nancy
myers is known for these for these
movies and for just movie uh casting
movie locations like houses that none of
us would ever be able to afford but like
want to live in because like of course
like cameron diaz's house is just so
crazy over the top dream la house but
then also kate winslet's house is like
the perfect most idyllic british cottage
that also nobody can afford like let's
be real um
but she's just like built this i don't
know it's just it's an industry of of
these type of stories and i i find them
to be really
like i don't know you just kind of love
them and you think of things like like
the
the intern and something's got to give
and it's complicated billy do you have
like a favorite one of hers besides this
obviously that that you won
yeah
yeah she worked on it but i think that
that was an anomaly for nancy myers
because she it wasn't her original
source it wasn't hers yeah that that one
i think you're right she did such a
great job with what women want she does
with it because it's such a ridiculous
idea but it's also something that as
women you always go i wish you knew what
was happening inside my head
but also the performances are so
real
that you are
you are completely sucked into this um
really big
idea and really big sort of formal um
theme and it's really clever but also
really emotional yeah and then also i
mean like look i mean this is the woman
who started with private benjamin and
then gave us baby boom like yeah there's
just like like let's really talk and
another thing too like rob reiner
obviously gets a ton of credit for the
princess bride but that's i mean sorry
uh sorry princess spray uh father of the
bride uh that that was her screenplay as
well like oh my god yeah
yeah like i said
princess brian i met father gray um i
have to ask you do you have like a a
person you've watched this with or like
do you have like a personal sort of like
because like i feel for me this is like
a girlfriend zoom movie like 100
yeah like
like no man wants to watch this film
with except for mark
i've had like
probably four boyfriends since this um
like meaningful relationship since this
film has been around and none of them
have wanted to watch
um they can do the beginning and then
they're done um
it's definitely a it's definitely a girl
like
you know just a sort of sad drunken
girlfest not necessarily just sad either
it doesn't have to be sad it could be um
it could just be
giggly giggly christmas girl
yeah i'm down for it why there needs to
be wine there's a lot of great wine
moments in this movie and i think uh i
think we gotta keep with it and you
should show it to somebody that's gen z
so they know what a blockbuster looks
like oh my god yeah absolutely and
people are smoking inside which is just
such a lovely fond memory
you know like when you see it like oh it
was fun
yeah
right back in the days before i had to
hold the table for everyone smoking so
you go out with everyone they all go
outside and then you look like the ass
because you're just that no no no
there's 10 people that i'm with i'm
taking up this whole table they're all
outside smoking right now yeah
but i can watch this movie i mean look i
can throw this movie on at any time and
i don't i don't need a season i just i
think it's a good vacation inspiration
movie too because there must have been a
boom in home swapping after this movie
came out because it was a successful
movie it did over 200 million dollars of
business worldwide so i think a lot of
people saw it and they're like i even if
it wasn't home swapping necessarily can
i trace back to was this the movie that
started the germ in somebody's brain to
create airbnb i'm gonna go with that
hey yeah honestly this is before the
apps because i don't even think many
people had smartphones at this point
right like those
god aging aging ourselves look
i could talk about this movie for
literally hours and i would but um we
definitely want to make sure we leave
enough time to talk about your film uh
rare beast because first of all like i
said we we kicked off by talking about
the fact that we saw this is something
that you
wrote and directed so um i i just if you
can um set us up with you know what is
rare beast and what do people have in
store
so i guess the film in like the
headlines of the film are i wrote this
film when what nine years ago my second
son had just been born and i was leaving
my 20s into my 30s and i felt like all
the um
the cultural messaging and the cultural
steer was that we can have it all as
women and by the way you should have it
all and you should be really good at it
all
and
all i could even though maybe there was
some good will in that messaging but all
i could sort of see around me was like
common crisis where everybody was
attempting to do that and falling apart
like it was costing
women um and there seemed to be this
the beginning of this huge shed anxiety
which i think has probably got
progressively worse since i started
writing this film
i just i wanted to talk about um what it
really looked like and what it costs to
be a modern woman and um not sugarcoat
it and
and you know it's heightened as a movie
i think but it's it's dealing with the
sort of um
is quite divisive in a way this film um
and it will entirely depend on what
you've experienced in your life as to
whether you can
marry with these characters because
you're meeting them and they're all at
the end of their rope and they're really
really course with each other but
that they have nothing to lose and you
you get that from the beginning and so
it's just a journey it's a journey of a
sort of modern relationship and and not
just a sort of romantic relationship but
a relationship with the the protagonists
with herself
and her her own sense of worth and self
being um
self care i'll preface this question by
by saying you've you've known me for
about 20 minutes now billy you probably
can already tell i'm super lazy
it is it is beyond me to think about how
somebody can can can write something
like this can star in something like
this but the directorial aspect of this
it's your directorial debut
where does the energy come from because
it's just got to be such a a little of
it must be trial and error but like i'm
just so in awe of people who can direct
and who can lead and can just get an
entire crew to seek out this one vision
that started with you so what was that
process like what were some of the
surprises the curveballs that you didn't
expect being your first feature that you
directed
um okay so the curveballs were
well
the first challenge was getting it
financed because on paper this film is
like are you joking there's there's four
very unlikable characters it's really
theatrical
it's very aggressive and it's even worse
when you just cold read it
so there's so that was a challenge it's
getting the right person behind it to
champion it and
and convince wealthy people to give us
their money
um that was hard
but
it's a game of nerves making an
independent feature and i've been in
them
as an actor and you're not you know it
doesn't really touch the sides you know
what i mean as an actor you like
shielded from pretty much
everything
um and which is why we're all so spoiled
and gross
[Laughter]
and then
as a producer even
it's it's just a game of nerves as to
whether the film will be finished be
made
be
completed be
um
make it to post have money for post
um
then promotion like
so many things can go wrong when you
have no money in no time and what you're
relying on heavily is
good will from the crew um
you know and that is at all asked after
a certain point
um so the sort of game of nerves of it
was um that was that was the bit i found
most challenging also i was pregnant so
it was
physically challenging oh come on this
is this is huge
you and emery mcdonald's
you and emeril fennell and i think greta
too all like had these like crazy movies
that they pushed out but i'm a fan of
that um filmmaker and friend that i know
and um incredible cinematographer rachel
morrison shot this
totally dope commercial about working
moms because she's one of the big
proponents for how
that needs to be a part of filmmaking
now making it to where these female
filmmakers and storytellers and so i
feel like when women like you do that
it's like look you didn't lose your
ability to craft stories just because
you're incubating a human and it just
makes what you did even more and serena
williams for winning a tennis tournament
too like that one's like crazy
i like have a hard time getting out of
bed each morning so the fact that
they're able to do all of those other
things in combination again super women
literally uh but also since this is
directorial debut and you talked about
this earlier i guess it's a gift that
you've had such this incredible career
because you've gotten to work with both
you know um in television and in film
these directors that you can pick up
things from but i could also say it's
like but it's also sort of like you know
but not this like it's like when you get
engaged and you go to a bunch of
weddings and you're like
not this um what was something
that you sort of saw
that you were kind of like okay i'm
really going to take this great thing
and maybe what was something you don't
have to say to the person um where
you're like when i get on set behind the
camera this is this is not the way i
want to really execute it because i
think that's beneficial both what to do
and what not to do yeah definitely i
mean um
i certainly know how to talk to
actors at least i think i do i find that
more often than not direct is probably
because of the nature of the job which
is where you sit back and look at things
and observe in your voyeuristic on and
there's always seems to be some sort of
social
um
delay with directors where like they
just totally
um
[Music]
not all of them but a lot of them
aren't always socially adept to deal
with very sensitive people which is
actors you know like it's crazy to me
some of those happy things the director
says to actors to get what they want
sometimes it works
but it but but sometimes it really
really really doesn't so um i felt very
comfortable with the actors
i also cast it really well i think i
knew what these people could do they
have a lot of background in theater
and
i'd let them just go with it i didn't
feel like i had to um
steer them all the time like they were
really capable competent skilled people
but
you know i mean that was i guess that
was my strong suit in the filming of it
i that was something i felt comfortable
doing and something that i i definitely
pulled from as my own experience as an
actor it's getting very dark in my house
is it too dark for you guys or is it
getting weird now no no we can totally
see you it's very it's very um ambiance
trust me yeah into the night
perfect lighting for me it's almost like
you're about to tell us a really scary
i'm story at the little what the little
image of myself like this is like me at
camp this is like being at camp now
i like it dig it in gather around
billy's going to tell us the story now
which is first of all in select theaters
and on demand august 20th so make sure
y'all check it out i guess my last
question for you real quick billy is is
it when you're writing something like
this did you find it easier to write for
yourself
or for other
people
well
i guess when i was writing it i didn't
imagine me saying it so
it all felt like it was for someone else
okay um even though i knew i was
going to be in it i didn't imagine it
for myself
but it's very satisfying writing things
for other actors it's really really
satisfying yeah it's really really going
to make them safe for your friends it's
really satisfying like
putting some little things in there that
personal gripes you know what i mean
yeah that was the thing i felt about it
because it's it's chaotic in so many
ways but i also feel like that's a
female mind especially a female mind
that's trying to just deconstruct
whatever a dude is thinking which again
that is like a math problem unto itself
but like you really i think kind of
captured modern dating in a way that
like i wouldn't expect given
like is this like were you just robbing
all of your single friends that you
would call over and be like all right
about this dude this week
like what is the yeah
no actually i felt not all of it some of
it yeah and but some of it was from guys
as well it wasn't just from girlfriend
some of it was like
the male frustration with um
not earning as much money as their
counterpart you know or um
oh me too me too like like just just
some of them just
not feeling it someone being being very
put out by this um modern um female
liberation i guess
um so yeah that's quite um fun to expose
yeah it is equal like this is not yes it
definitely dissects the the female
aspect she's our main protagonist but
this is more about modern dating and i
think that's why
it's really going to be interesting uh
for folks to see it it is out now um
rare beast is out in select theaters and
available on demand please check it out
um billy i i cannot say thank you enough
for your time and chatting about this
the next thing you put out please come
back you can you can take us to task for
any movie and i will have to say this
like legitimately secret diary call girl
is probably one of my all-time favorite
shows like i can i can quote passages of
it which is sad for me to say to you but
i i literally adored that show i am
still mad you left him on that pier
oh i know
that's like girl like you're lucky i
like you because i was crying when i saw
that just kidding
she's a racist but hey you know what but
that made the story and that's the
character like i can't be mad at it as a
writer because that is the character and
you just performed it so great and you
don't get that beautiful you know
find someone like me you and the adele
in the background if she doesn't leave
here
all right well thank you again billy uh
we're going to let you get out of here
so you can go i'm just going to go to
bed now
i was going to say yeah are you just
getting back yeah he's going to go back
into the darkness like jesus i'm gonna
go move into the darkness and tackle a
bear
be very careful stumbling around in the
dark and this is this is the new crew
for me this is the 2021 holiday viewing
experience we all need to get on a zoom
together and and fire up we'll do a
double feature of the holiday and then
your movie rare beast that's that's
going to be my my 2021 holiday season oh
and i almost forgot confusing time yeah
i almost forgot billy
a movie tv buff is there anything that
we should be watching maybe something um
that's over there that'll come over here
soon is there anything you want to
recommend for folks to check out like i
just started white lotus and whoa that
one is different
i haven't seen anything
recently um
i
oh god i'm not cultured at all anymore
what can i say you have a newborn you
have a newborn you're allowed you're
allowed you guys
have no recommendations
i talked to tom i actually spoke to tom
ellis like a month after he had his kid
and he's like he's like i will talk to
you about peppa pig more than i will
talk to you about what's in theaters so
you're you're totally allowed i i will i
want to know something that's quite
sweet tom ellis's daughter and my son
are in a band together shut the front
door wow
and i love both of y'all y'all were
great interviews both of you
they're in a band called galaxy and they
played their first show um
about a month ago and they're really
cute
we're supposed to be talking about
they're losing their recommendations
the fact that your kids are in a band
together the talent
the talent i love it i'm gonna tell him
we're supposed to talk to him for
lucifer i'm gonna tell him that we
chatted this is so cool i will okay
thank you again billy this has been
great
bye guys
[Music]
she's so fun like seriously like first
of all she's in london and so she was
way past her bedtime to speak with us
which i really appreciate but she was
still like tons of fun and you can tell
like loves movies and i like her like
dry cynical wit like that's that's my
level of comedy nothing against you mark
we were doing our own sort of holiday
reenactment because you're in los
angeles she's in london and i just hope
i wasn't the roofest soul character i
hope i wasn't jasper
i mean let's be honest we're all a
jasper in someone's story that is the
one thing that life will teach us yeah
in everyone's story i just want to be
the really really old guy with some good
tails to spin during dinner well i'm not
gonna dispute that but arthur also
worked at hollywood for several decades
and so
i'm gonna go ahead and say there's some
chapters he wouldn't want
okay before we like slander
arthur the most lovable character in
history uh
anymore um this is what's great about
this one is
it's found a secondary audience as we
talked about like this is one like i've
seen holiday marathons i'm pretty sure
that tnt
does like a holiday marathon am i right
am i wrong yes
yeah
they will they'll marathon that but
sometimes i think lifetime does
a holiday marathon a lifetime might not
even wait until like christmas time
proper i think it's like the day after
thanksgiving lifetime is like open the
floodgates let's get the holiday let's
usher in the christmas season yeah
and look this is like kind of a timeless
uh show but lucy and our lovely
researcher mark hofmeyer let us know
that there's actually
a netflix wrong com that is gonna maybe
sort of like plot like prey on this sort
of premise but maybe reverse it it's
aston kutcher reese witherspoon your
place or mine
and it was written by the girl that
wrote devil wears prada so i'm gonna
give her the benefit of the doubt okay
ashley pitcher and reese witherspoon
yeah okay two best friends who live on
opposite coasts swap homes for a week
and see their whole lives change are
they gonna fall in love or are they
gonna fall in love with other people but
they may fall in love with other people
this is straight up disrespectful
i don't know
and we don't need another one
i mean look
it's written by the woman who did the
devil worse prada and anybody who can
give meryl streep a line that's all i'm
going to give him the benefit of the
doubt if she had written
going the distance probably not
i like that movie but i'm not giving you
the benefit i'm not giving it the
benefit of the doubt though that's what
i'm saying like devil's worse prada is
one of those things where like you made
this i'm giving you the benefit of the
doubt robert rodriguez he made dust hold
on for the rest of his career i'm giving
him the benefit of the doubt that's what
got me to spy kids opening weekend
ladies and gentlemen
so
there's certain things like if you make
it i'm gonna give you the benefit of the
doubt so i'm sorry there's a lack of
vampires in the spy kids franchise to
satiate your taste but i mean look
if you look at the holiday i think one
of the cool things that i learned behind
the scenes on this thanks to mark
hoffmeyer a great researcher was that
kate winslet apparently had never had a
a movie role written for her like with
her in mind until this movie nancy myers
told her that she's like hey no i
actually wrote this with you in mind and
kate's like get right out of town she's
like no no i i wrote this for you and
apparently nancy myers saw jack black in
school of rock and is like i just i like
this guy
he's speaking to me he's communicating
with me as an audience member and i i
think in retrospect it might have been
considered like
i don't know if risky's the right word
because i don't know that jack black
would turn anybody off no i mean for a
studio picture yeah like let's be honest
they they want to basically cast someone
like taran edgerton who's the pretty boy
they cast when they want to pretend that
a pretty boy's not a pretty boy right
and so jack black just walks that that
fine line of not being the classic
look like a movie star somebody worthy
of kate winslet in our superficial
judging eyes but he also isn't so
schwabby that her getting with him at
the end you're like this would never
happen like you kind of believe it also
i would be remiss if i didn't say as
much as i love the holiday and i love
nancy myers work she does fall in this
like filmmaker who never believes that
anybody brown has shown up in some of
these locations like she's got a rep for
that and i'm not gonna like not point it
out because look i think somebody said
nancy myers the woman who shows you rich
white people's kitchen
throughout various settings um oh i can
speak to that sure i mean i'm never
gonna own property that looks anything
like even the surrey house much less the
los angeles glacial state that cameron
diaz lives on i mean that is just that's
another level i don't even know that i
would be able to afford either one of
those properties for like a week on an
airbnb airbnb yeah those are airbnb lux
and i'm not living the airbnb lux
lifestyle like let's be real although i
will say um both of us are getting to a
certain age somebody tweeted this the
other day and it made me think of this
movie a little bit too because it said
i've reached the point in my life where
i will never
enjoy an airbnb over a nice hotel and i
think i've reached that point in my life
as well i'm there but then sometimes you
just get an airbnb and like i don't need
to get into the culture
like if i if i'm traveling somewhere i
will put myself into the culture when i
deem fit but i also want to be able to
retreat to a nice static hermetically
sealed yeah yeah yes i still want to be
in a normal creature comfort hotel which
i do really enjoy hotel in the fancy
lobby water but i think my my final
thing on the holiday is this jacqueline
is if we're looking at the future of
these two relationships i think that
jack black and kate winslet's characters
have
10 kids minimum i think they do nothing
but procreate i think absolutely that's
what they do jude law and cameron diaz
would make the most beautiful children
on the planet i don't think they have
one kid i think that they just focus on
the two that he had
absolutely and meanwhile jack black and
kate winslet are making a whole football
team i i absolutely kind of agree with
you on that like they're gonna fill
up
amanda the cameron diaz's uh character's
house full of children like absolutely
because look they're both like home
things like she's a book editor he's
playing the piano
that that's a lot of sex that can happen
in between those two activities let's be
real you know i have a question real
quick
um because you guys brought him up a
bunch before we move on
this is gonna sound really bad
um
arthur who you guys brought up a bunch
in the conversation with billy
played by eli wallach can you
tell me like why he's a big deal
because i remember like watching him in
the movie but i also know like isn't he
like a famous movie star or writer or
something from like actual holly like
what's the deal with eli wallach do you
guys know his background
so he's a famous
character actor
from like
old school time so like he
was in the good and bad the ugly
one
um he was in seven he was in he
basically probably has the dirt on every
major hollywood star from clark gable
to clint eastwood to whoever else in
between like he probably and you see a
little bit of it in the movie he
probably would it's just that guy who
you just want to invite to dinner just
just to hear the stories like i wouldn't
i enjoy talking i would not say a word
in the presence of eli walk at the
dinner table just because i want to hear
everything that he remembers from his
time in hollywood yeah thank you all
again for listening we want to
definitely thank billy piper you all can
check out rare beasts playing select
theaters and on streaming on vod uh also
want to thank the illustrious crew back
here at rotten tomatoes is wrong we have
brian pettis producie lucy and my
partner in crime mr mark ellis
wherever you're listening to us please
please please rate subscribe follow i
don't even know are there stars and
hearts where you're listening just make
sure folks know that you're a fan of the
podcast and if you have a suggestion for
us for a film that we should break down
next please email us at art he is wrong
at rotten tomatoes and what we're doing
next week
ooh ooh is it chill girls
it's a surprise
oh secret okay it's probably gonna be
show girls thing
it should be show girls show your face
against it i'm gonna have a good time
either way i would too all right guys
we'll see y'all next time on rotten
tomatoes is strong bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you